hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game you guys suggested a lot
of you have suggested it as it is pretty
incredible some of you are even saying
that it could be even better than Wei's
Immortal game against uh Lazaro Briton
Batista that was played in 2016. uh if
you haven't seen it do check it out and
you will be able to make a comparison uh
as I I can't really uh make up it is a
splendid game is it better I have no
idea if you want to check out the link
in the description below first link is
um uh the the game that is currently
deemed as Wei's Immortal game so here
he's playing in the Chinese League it is
uh round two and he's facing
International Master also from China uh
Lu yipping uh and uh well let's just
dive straight into it it uh yeah kicks
off very early so yeah you guys will
enjoy it uh Wei opens with D4 we have D5
uh by Luis uh C4 going for the Queen's
Gambit and now Pawn to E6 declining the
Gambit Knight to C3 with Knight to F6
and now C captures on the five we have
eight captures and Bishop to G5 so the
exchange variation of the positional
line of the Queen's Gambit declined we
have Pawn to C6 Ponte E3 and now Bishop
D7 uh sorry Bishop D7 the most common uh
move here Bishop the five second most
popular so still uh the main line and
now you play something like Queen to F3
here you go after the bishop where you
play Bishop to D3 or you play Queen to
B3 go after the B7 Pawn or you play
Knight to F3 so many a very nice
developing moves uh can be played here
but the way it goes for Pawn to G4 and
already uh there are only a handful of
games that reach this exact same
position one uh player that has played
G4 is of course um uh Badu baba but he
played pretty much any weird move in any
position uh so okay the bishop is
attacked and you can't capture it if you
capture then uh White just starts
trading and wins material Bishop
captures Bishop capture Sandy one Bishop
capture Sun d8 King capture San Diego
now Rook captures on D1 and of course if
you count to the pieces white is up a
full night so of course you can't do
that after the spawn to G4 Bishop back
to E6 and now uh there is a game where
Bishop to D3 was played that's the
jobava game but here we have pawned the
H3 and now there is also uh uh a a known
game where not b37 was played but here
we have Pawn to H5 and it is now already
as of move eight that we have a
completely new game and of course those
are the games that we enjoy most the
sooner the completely new game comes the
more we enjoy the game it's it's how how
it works G captures on H5 okay you give
up one pawn it but at least you stop
White's expansion and now Queen to B6
pulling pressure on the B2 pawn and if
white gives it up then The Rook will be
attacked the Knight will be attacked and
it's not going to be that easy to defend
uh but Wei doesn't care Bishop captures
an F6 Queen characters on B2 now
threatening to pick up the Knight with
check uh Knight to G to E2 defending the
Knight and now Bishop to B4 not worrying
about the bishop and F6 you want to play
Bishop captures on C3 so okay where he
says Bishop captures and G7 I'm I will
throw in this um a nice Vision took uh
bishop captress and C3 with check Knight
captures and queen captures and C3 with
check and now King to E2 and now look at
this position it's move 14 this is Way
East position what is this I mean it's
uh not not something that we see very
often and you can't really go Queen to C
for check you would like to make
something out of this position but you
can't if you go Queen to C4 check King
F3 and now the queen and the Rook are
hanging so here you just resign as black
so after King K2 Rook captures an H5
this is the absolute best move and now
Rook to B1 going after Rook captures on
B7 and here Queen to C4 check is played
you could also play a nice calm move
like Pawn to B6 and then let's say Rook
to C1 attacks the queen queen A3 and he
broke the G1 King to E7 and the game
continues both King's uh in in a very
nice opposition here on E2 and D7 and
again not your everyday position but you
know it's playable for both white and
black however after Rook B1 Queen to C4
check was played and now comes King back
to E1 and now Queen captures an A2 the
problem with persisting with Queen to C3
check is that now white could just block
and if you trade for example captures
captures and B6 yes the material is
equal but the plays on both sides of the
board we has the bishop Fair White's
Position will be uh somewhat better so
instead after King T1 uh Queen captures
and 80 was played uh Louis ping grabs
another pawn and now Rook to A1 attacks
the queen queen B2 and now okay if you
capture on H5 then Queen captures and A1
happens by the way he says that's
exactly what we need so Queen captures
on H5 Queen captures an A1 with check
King to E2 and now the problem for black
is that even though uh the the uh white
king is an E2 the black queen is already
deep in White's camp that F3 square is
such a safe haven for the white king uh
there's no way to get to it so here King
to D7 was played and queen to h8 now now
you can put the bishop on F6 play Queen
to d8 and this would be will be
Checkmate so uh weeping has to be very
very careful on how he proceeds here the
problem is uh imagine if you could
somehow check the white king and if
white king goes to F3 if your Bishop was
an F5 Play Bishop D for check it all
looks very nice but it's absolutely
worthless uh problem is that even if you
prepare this let's Bishop to F5 because
you're not in any serious danger of
getting checkmated uh of course white
will have to prepare it first now Queen
tabi to track king of three and even
Bishop to E4 check does nothing for
black king to G3 and you have nothing
better you can capture The Rook but now
Queen captures an F7 check and you're
getting checkmated whatever you play for
example King the C8 um you're gonna
deliver a check with the queen queen to
C7 with King 67 with check Bishop D5
check King goes to B6 and now Queen to
C8 d8 will be Checkmate as the bishop on
on F1 is doing such a fine job covering
all of these squares and the pawn covers
the C5 Square so that's the problem with
a slow move like Bishop to F5 although
you really want to play it so here Pawn
to B5 was played creating some more room
on the queen side for the king and this
will simply not do the only way to play
was Queen to B1 uh but who's to make
sense of what's what in a position like
this so here B5 was played Rook to G1 uh
the here also Bishop D5 works very
nicely then the the queen can come just
uh come in but Rook to G1 was played and
now Bishop to F5 but it's not a problem
just Queen to f8 putting pressure on the
pawn here and now uh Bishop to D3 check
this is a beautiful maneuver by Lou
yipping uh if uh we accept then it's a
draw if King captures on D3 then Queen
to D1 check and you cannot Escape of
course the pawn covers D squares you
have to go to C3 you know the C1 check
you have to go back and we have a
repetition because if you go up the
board then you quickly get destroyed
Queen B2 checking day five Queen to C3
with check you can block okay Queen to
B4 but it doesn't matter Queen to A1
check and you have no squares for the
black for the white king the queen has
the
uh be sacrificed and once you do that
it's just going to be a very nice
Checkmate so instead after Bishop to D3
check King to F3 was played and now
comes King to C7 starting to run away uh
if you try Bishop G6 to defend the pawn
it doesn't really matter just Bishop F6
and the King hunt continues uh so
nothing there so instead King to C7 uh
we have Bishop to E5 with check King the
B7 and now Queen to E7 with check King
the A6 and now uh Here Comes Bishop
captures and D3 you could also play King
to G2 to prepare it to guard your Rook
on G1 by the way he says no need I'm
just gonna sacrifice the rook and G1 or
rather the exchange here so Queen
captures Sanji when you have the capture
otherwise you're just down too much
material and now Bishop to F5 and now do
you see the real threat the real thread
is Bishop C7 followed by Bishop to C8
Checkmate a beautiful double bishop
checkmate also one of the uh one of the
nicer examples on why Bishops are so
much better than knights in uh position
like these so Queen to D1 check was
played King to F4 and now Queen to D2
trying to get some sort of a Perpetual
here against the white king but King to
G3 nothing to worry about Queen T1 uh
Bishop to C7 now preparing Bishop to C8
Checkmate and uh okay you can stop it
but not for very long Queen to G1 check
was played King to F3 and now Queen to
G8 stopping Bishop to C8 and now many
moves are winning here but there's the
one maneuver that's simply instant
resigns for black so feel free to pause
the video and try to find the absolute
best move for white here while I give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on realizing that the
queen must come to C7 not the bishop and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is a move like Bishop to F4
or Bishop to E5 or Bishop to G3
basically you just move the Bishop from
this diagonal and you vacated the C7
Square uh for the for the White Queen uh
here on F4 it it kind of makes sense as
it covers uh um the more squares on the
board and you don't really have a move
uh for example King the queen date Queen
to C7 will be played and there is no
defense against Bishop to C8 to
Checkmate the only way to defend is to
start giving up more material and
there's uh I mean there's just no way to
live so instead after King the G8 Pawn
the H4 was played I mean any move is
winning but this was just uh winning on
the spot uh so here Queen to h8 and now
King to G3 we have Queen to G7 check
King to H3 and queen to h8 why we missed
that one and found this one well because
now he will take all the squares away
from The Black Queen Bishop G4 Pawn to
F6 as black is really without a move and
now Bishop to E6 taking away one more
Square from the black queen and now you
really have no squares on the background
you can you can move the queen and then
Bishop to see it will be Checkmate or
you can try another move but I mean it
doesn't really work King the B7 was
played here Bishop to d8 check opens up
a discovery and he was in this position
unmove 37 at the Lou yipping resigned to
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here now the queen no longer covers
the add the CH squared and that's it
once the king moves King to A6 at Bishop
to C8 will be Checkmate and there you
have it another uh well it didn't happen
on the board but if the game continued
another beautiful double bishop
checkmate uh so there we have it another
way Masterpiece he just comes out of
nowhere and you know completely destroys
everyone uh uh now uh while I'm looking
at it I might have even gotten his uh
reading wrong because he has been doing
incredibly well uh playing he won in in
round one uh also so let me just check
this the live ratings here uh so let me
just check that yeah he's a 27 34.9 here
on the live live ratings list so he is
doing better than he is here in the
video but these are live ratings and in
the video I always put the ratings that
come on uh come out on the first of each
month so okay he's he's doing uh very
well uh so yeah that's the game I hope
you guys enjoyed it once again a
beautiful double bishop checkmate would
happen if the game had continued if you
guys haven't seen a Waze game from 2017
against
um uh Lazaro Brooklyn Batista do check
it out will be the first link in the
description below it's a bit of an older
video but you get a chance to see how
you know the channel progressed and you
know how the videos are compared to the
older videos and you can also compare
the game so I would very much enjoy it
if you guys settled it is is this uh the
new Immortal or thus is uh Immortal from
2017 still stands uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it I would
like to thank Derek King Alexandria De
Rola uh Dean bodenham uh made some Yaya
and the David quintillion for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions such as this one
uh and whatever else happens in the
Chess World so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day and tomorrow a big surprise we
will have a license uh we will have a
live stream on this channel I will have
two guests and we will be discussing
many great things I will not spoil it
just yet I will announce it in the next
video but you know just uh just a heads
up until then see you soon